someday and that day may never come i'll
call upon you to do a service for me
but uh until that day
except this justice is a gift on my
daughter's wedding day
yes
welcome to your weekly ticket
jamie foxx is in final talks to reprise
his role as electro in spider-man 3
which stars tom holland
and is being made by sony and marvel
this third holland-led spider-man movie
is set to begin filming in atlanta this
fall with returning actors like zendaya
marisa tomei jacob babylon and tony
revolori reprising their roles
walt disney studios will be making a
follow-up to their 2019 the lion king
with oscar winner barry jenkins set to
direct
jeff nathanson who wrote the most recent
lion king movie has penned the initial
script for jenkins reimagining
the film will use the motion capture and
visual effects technology used by john
favreau in the last big screen iteration
and 2016's the jungle book
jenkins celebrated the news by saying
having the opportunity to work with
disney on expanding this magnificent
tale of friendship
love and legacy while furthering my work
chronicling the lives and souls of folk
within the african diaspora is a dream
come true
and oscar isaac and jake gyllenhaal will
star in a film about the making of the
godfather and the legendary
battles that went into making the 1972
classic
the film titled francis and the
godfather will be directed by oscar
winner barry levinson
isaac will play francis ford coppola and
gyllenhaal will star as
studio head robert evans while the
godfather is widely considered one of
the greatest films
ever made the production was not without
its difficulties
copeland paramount had several arguments
including over budget
location and casting with coppola having
to fight to get marlon brando and al
pacino to star
the invisible man was a giant success at
the box office and vod
and there's been tons of announcements
of new blumhouse revamps of classic
universal monsters
and there's no better way to start off
october than by speaking with
horror movie expert perry nemeroff and
she's gonna guide us through the legacy
of past films
attempts at dark universes and monster
movies to come
harry there's so many classic monsters
which is your favorite monster or
monster movie i
was very tempted to go creature from the
black lagoon for my favorite
monster movie but i feel like it's the
cliche answer but i have to top that
with frankenstein
frankenstein is one of the best of the
best and i have a very interesting
journey to frankenstein and to many of
my favorite horror films for that matter
i am obsessed with the movie scream it
was my it's my second favorite movie of
all time and if you remember
in the video store scene in that movie
that was my first experience seeing
any frankenstein footage and it's like
one of the most iconic scenes in the
movie so
because i loved scream that drove me not
only to check out frankenstein but also
movies like halloween and so many other
classics but frankenstein has proven to
be a
a big one for me and i also think it's
it's kind of attached to my love of
jurassic park too and just the whole
idea of what people do
with the power we wield and you know
it's a line in jurassic park
also trying to weigh whether or not we
actually
should do what we're capable of doing
and
because of that frankenstein is hands
down one of the most heartbreaking of
all of the classic monster
movies absolutely he's like at the core
of the misunderstood monster
genre sort of thing right oh my god
misunderstood and
and just abused he never he never even
had a fighting chance and that's why
that scene
the the one shot of him looking up at
the sunlight
breaks my heart every single time i
watch the movie because you just know
it's
hopeless for him are you one of the
people that gets triggered when they
call
uh the the monster frankenstein and not
frankenstein's monster yeah cause it's
just wrong
you know fair enough i have no i have no
horse in this battle
all right uh so which monster movie do
you think
deserves a new take i know they've got a
lot in development but which one do you
think deserves a new take see part of
the reason why i was okay with
committing to frankenstein for that
first answer is because i have to go
creature from the black lagoon for this
one i
i absolutely love that movie if i'm not
watch if i had my choice
of classic universal monster movies to
watch i'd probably go frankenstein first
but this movie is not far behind
this is one of those ones that has been
in the works for a remake
for so so long now i think it was john
landis who wanted
jack arnold to direct one john carpenter
was involved in one peter jackson was
offered the opportunity to direct one
and he didn't and then the one that got
me really riled up was when breck eisner
had the opportunity so
first brett eisner got the opportunity
to direct a remake of creature of the
black lagoon
but then he wound up prioritizing the
crazies first and the crazies
is one of my favorite horror movies of
the last decade i think it's an
excellent remake of the george romero
original so
i see the crazies and then i'm just
dying for him to finally get into
creature from the black lagoon and
sadly that project fell apart and i
guess it is one of the few
of like the og monsters that we don't
have any momentum
for a new remake right now so i i think
that's the one
yeah i think he's a little out of the
the limelight there but let's say you
get to cast the creature from the black
lagoon who you cast him
oh it's a no-brainer and it's it's like
the most obvious answer in the world
because you can't star in the shape of
water
get absolutely no academy award honor
yourself for playing the creature
doug jones doug jones yes
so good absolutely yup can't can't have
them as a monster enough
you mentioned that there's upcoming ones
there's a there's a lot in the works
which one are you the most excited about
of the ones coming up i feel like you
should be able to guess this because i
think we talked about this the last time
i was on
how big of a fan i am of lee 1l i think
he
is so so talented so i have to go
wolfman on this
one because leonel you don't make
upgrade and then also
invisible man and not have me really
hyped for your next movie but
it's a wolfman movie starring ryan
gosling who in their right mind would
say no to that
it's gonna be it's gonna be the new
twilight i am
all for it i don't know about calling it
the new twilight but that's like another
big question mark with that too
is part of the reason why a wolfman
movie is so
difficult to make or any werewolf movie
for that matter is because
the effects needed to actually pull that
off they're very
difficult to create convincingly and i i
got a lot of faith that leonel can
probably do it if he made
the i'm not gonna spoil anything but if
he made the the invisible man
work visually the way he did i have a
feeling he's gonna have a smart approach
to wolfman but
i'm very curious to see what the makeup
or effects department does with that
you're right he was able to choose uh
make what could have been really cheesy
and he made it work and i think that's
i think that's why you're excited about
the upcoming ones from him right
oh i'm so excited he's he's so talented
and if you look at
upgrade and then moving over to
invisible man i mean
his work was still excellent in upgrade
but you could see him kind of
you know honing his craft and really
holding on to a very specific style and
improving it from film to film so if he
stays true to that
i can't wait to see where he takes it in
this one
me too i think it's in the right hands
well thank you very much perry for
joining us where can
people find you you guys can find me on
twitter and instagram at pmroff and over
on collider
all right well thank you so much
available to watch at home mulan you're
a war hero
you've already made many great
sacrifices
my father cannot fight so i will take
his place
when the emperor of china issues an
official order that one man per family
must serve
in the imperial army to defend the
country from the northern invaders
mulan the eldest daughter of an honored
warrior steps in to take the place of
her ailing father
masquerading as a man she is tested
every step of the way and must harness
her inner strength and embrace
her true potential it's an epic journey
that will transform her into an honored
warrior
and earn her the respect of a grateful
nation and a proud father
nikki karo directed the film which had a
reported budget of 200 million
making mulan the most expensive
live-action film ever directed by a
female filmmaker
and also available to watch at home
cutthroat city
got a wife in the sun now you won't have
to deal with
this type of assistance the ninth ward
isn't covered
new orleans nothing short of apocalyptic
first they flood us
then they pushing us out this happened
just how they wanted this dramatic
thriller follows a group of young men
who returned to new orleans after
hurricane katrina
receiving no help from fema they turn to
local gangsters for help
out of options the four friends must
reluctantly accept and offer to pull off
a dangerous heist in the heart of new
orleans
the film is directed by rizza and stars
shamik moore t.i
isaac gonzalez ethan hawk wesley snipes
kat graham and terence howard all right
well that's it for today but leave us a
comment and let us know if you'll be
checking out cutthroat city or mulan
and check out that list of fandango
now's universal monster movies
and let us know which one's your
favorite i'm kale and i'll see you next
[Music]
time